it's time now for a special
pre-valentine's day edition of CBS
morning's deals where we share items
that might make the perfect gift for
yourself or a loved one all at exclusive
discounts to start shopping go scan that
QR code on your screen right now hurry
up and do it or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle Elizabeth
lifestyle expert Elizabeth Warner is
with us right now good morning how are
you doing good morning I have to say
Happy Valentine's Day it's coming are
you prepared I am prepared you've got to
get ready but you have some gifts to
help me do so don't forget shop with us
cbsdeals.com shop along with us as we go
we'll start right off with you I'm
giving you the gift of a house for
Valentine's Day and I'm feeling a
massage on my feet all right so calm and
cozy this actually has a remote on it
that has heat adjustment and vibration
massage so think about this at the end
of a long day maybe you're one of those
people that always has cold feet aching
muscles aching legs you sit in this you
snuggle up you turn that heat on you
turn that vibration on now imagine
giving that as a gift that's a hug and
love the outside is a soft Velveteen the
inside is a really soft Sherpa this is
where it's at for Valentine's Day you
want to give the gifts of love and
comfort this is it right there so what
are we talking yes all right so right
now it is 40 off it's just
53.99 so you want to get that now
because we've had that on before and
it's super popular and this is going to
be it's a good time to go fast we all
know someone with cold feet everybody
and not just at home right think about
your office chair think about wherever
you are that your little feet are
getting cold or you need a massage and
yes if you're if your hubby doesn't do
well with the foot massage like maybe
Tony oh then Tony then um this will do
it for you yeah Tony said he's not good
at the massages so
I'm not a professional all right what do
we have here our hotel collection now
these are gorgeous candles this was
curated and brings us home essential oil
candles that smell like the scent in a
five-star hotel now think about
Valentine's Day you're going to light
the candle set the mood this one is
called my way it's got the scent of yes
a Tuscan Leather it's it's got Cedar in
it Sandalwood the smells are delicious
they're gift sets of either Two Three or
the five the five actually are all
different scents these have 50 hours of
burn Time Each these have 70 hours of
burn time each so this is a high-end
delicious smelling candle and yes it
will set the mood oh all right all right
right yes so these are 50 off now so
they're starting at just fifty dollars a
gift set wow that's a good price all
right so what do we have here all right
so Genevieve jewelry I fell in love with
these the minute I saw them they are
gorgeous they are sophisticated and you
can have luxury and not have to spend a
fortune so think about this they're all
actually layered in either 18 karat
yellow gold 18 karat rose gold or
platinum all the stones are hand placed
by craftspeople absolutely stunning and
check mine out by the way
you see this bling I've got going on
here hey Pop too yes and this is what's
great about this is you want to look
sophisticated and you want to have that
beautiful look but we're all modern day
women now right we go to the gym in the
morning then the grocery store I gotta
get the kids to school and at night I
want to go out with my Valentine my
hubby Alex and I still want to wear the
same earrings all day
aren't these beautiful so your wife your
girlfriend your daughters nieces aunts
this is the perfect gift now this is an
extraordinary deal it is 57 off these
are just
29.95 there's a great variety go on to
cbsdeals.com and look at all of them
because there is a great number that you
can choose from something for every girl
that loves to Dazzle I like that all of
those items yes so you can really set
the mood on that's right and think
you've got to get ordering now for
Valentine's Day so it's there on time
yeah I'm walking in just like this with
only the rose on oh oh hey honey I'm
home oh all right
thank you I love it thank you so much of
course we partner with all these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything that you saw scan the QR code
on your screen right now or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now
don't do it